Every time you make a change with Google, there is a period, sometimes it's like four days,
sometimes it's seven days that Google has to go and relearn, if you will, what changes you made.
So you go in, you change the ad copy and you notice there's a drop off. That's normal.
Okay. You went in and you change the ad copy. So there's a learning period. It's going to be four
to seven days before that starts picking up again. So for those of you that are sitting there,
watching one campaign like a hawk and just change, change, change, change, change and nothing ever
starts going. That's why. Okay. Set it up how we train, exactly how we train and leave it. If
you're not getting clicks, leave it a little bit longer. Then when you start getting clicks,
let's start addressing it. Okay. We're not, we're getting clicks. We're not getting calls. Look at
the landing page. We'll start diving into it. But if I could say anything, do your best to not go
and tweak it every five seconds, not going to mess with it every five seconds.